j'ai passé un très mauvais week end
ah oui quelque chose m'a angoissé je me
suis posé des questions il y a quelqu'un
dans cette équipe mais au plus tard le
1er degré l'un pour de vrai dit toujours
tout téléspectateur ici il ya quelqu'un
dans cette équipe est amoureux de vous
mais vraiment pour des degrés au premier
degré donc c'est caca mauvaise vue déjà
un ca les goûts et les couleurs ça ne se
discute avec à la main un amour sanaa la
porte est juste un avis et c'est
quelqu'un qui a un court pas contre a
déjà fait signer ou pas
vous réglez ce mois ci pourquoi nous
révéler quelque chose me dit que tout à
l'heure j'ai quelque chose d'arriver à
cette question pour l'instant de siaulai
se calment merci enfin mettez personnes
en porte à faux
bien entendu au passage j'en sais rien
non non attendez vous dire des vérités
je pensais camille combal était amoureux
de vous c'est ce que nous pensons tous
on est ensemble
vous êtes en couple est marié maintenant
et une autre personne est amoureuse de
vous c'est matthieu delormeau
[Rires]
sur quoi vous basez tu veux prendre la
place de camille combal il ya dix ans
loges jeudi soir avant que nous rentrons
tout sénat qu'il vous trouve est mignon
que vous êtes c'est craquant ce que la
ville avait du charme c'est pire parce
que c'est faux pas trop d'accord il vous
a regardé énamouré d'amour quand ces
deux là mais c'est de l'amitié où j'ai
reniflé vos chemises quand vous n'êtes
pas dans notre loge envers sa femme
brooke et si la véronique les machos
mise à mon avis serait tombé dans les
pommes puis vous dire c'est pas possible
voilà mérite pas bien c'est évidemment
c'est drôle vous c'est vrai de fait du
charme c'est vrai et on m'avait pas je
crois qu'il épousait l'abattoir mais ça
c'est pas demain la veille tu vas me
pécho
[Musique]